man ist wütend auf sich selbst dass man
sich das selber angetan hat
konnte nicht mehr am leben teilnehmen
noch nichts ich konnte keine
freundschaft mehr pflegen keine meine
familie selbst meine familie hat mir
erst mal den rücken gekehrt
hätte ich damals das wissen wir was ich
heute habe er diesen mal machen lassen
ich war einfach noch die jugend
jährlich geträumt dass die implantate
draußen und ich bin im traum rumgehüpft
[Musik]
das ist natürlich ein ganz schwieriger
prozess wenn dieses eine teil was mich
so glücklich gemacht habe wo ich so viel
hoffnung reingesteckt hat dann auf
einmal probleme bereitet kann man sich
vorstellen dass das ein großer innerer
konflikt ist den mann austragen muss
[Musik]